[Music]
International chess professionals
converge in st. Louis for the 2017
spring chess classic hello chess fans
and welcome back to st. Louis
then Simon here for the st. Louis chess
club this is the second of four strong
quarterly tournaments will have this
year that feature international chess
professionals now this is a bigger event
than the last time we brought it to you
we have the regular groups a and B two
different ten player round robins
they'll compete over nine rounds but we
also have a special bonus for you we
have a six player double round-robin
called Group C it's actually a little
bit stronger than Group B and we'll tell
you all about it as we get going
the 2017 spring chess classic features a
combined prize fund of more than 50
grand win the top prize in group a that
will get you $6,000 $4,000 is the prize
for group V and the top prize for Group
C is $5,000 that's because Group C is
actually stronger than Group B and I am
sitting here with Grandmaster Alexander
Deepa Tov the former World Junior Chess
Champion himself II today he came away
with black with a win against
Grandmaster Mariko from Argentina
congratulations on your victory first of
all and take us through the game show us
what happened well so my fun to play sea
floor I didn't really care him and what
he's going to play because I hadn't
prepare at all and still like jet lag
and the most important for me was to get
enough sleep and not to paper we only
got here a couple days ago you were
saying I arrived like on Sunday and not
night a man stood one day ago I decided
to keep the coins on the board at the
bishop district when they say when I
think this is the best what he did King
g7 and here they might want one drunk he
blundered he should have played 25 once
again aiming to change points in the
right moment so and his next most would
be something like bishop it tonight if
one getting the night back into play so
maybe didn't know d8 we should eat
and of course luck is much much better
by that into anything concrete and since
I was in time trouble maybe I mean I
wouldn't been able to win this position
but my opponent made things easier for
me he played Bishop destroy now I think
like is winning by force Bishop c6 a
strong move I saw it in the last moment
of course rook did was the most personal
that comes into mind than 25 and maybe
still like why doesn't lose right away
like he played Bishop b3 and then Bishop
c6 I think it's winning 25 they should
pay for and black gains the control over
D file which is vital for this position
look you want to create in here he found
a very interesting defense night if one
I thought I mean like was a completed
completely completely winning but after
next one
I wasn't sure anymore but I think I did
the right thing I took on d3 everything
is four-stroke Texas ray if it takes all
night and simply rabito
should be made somewhere so no rookie
three group DEET rookie one if he took
on D Street and Luke takes if he takes
the Queen then like that and after rook
e1 or some of them of this Bishop d1
just killing because it pointed three
minutes week if night ish to then just
check and white position is completely
lost so he played of V one
I think Bishop d1 looks like the best
move because the agree to that doesn't
work if I take here then he takes to the
rook and I cannot invite on Tito just
now so but this would be one looks
strong enough once again he played move
but I didn't see King up to and here was
one minute or have him in the clock I
managed to find Robert I think this also
went on the spot
I was like other most maybe did not win
right away
so Tito maybe only move now and white
has Timo's okay rookie - rookie - or
King do you want
if Kings you won then I think bouquet -
and white is simply in sucks whatever
piece he moves he is just loading so I
think only movers to place g5 here and
then c4 because if he takes here then
his rook is lost if you move the knight
and it's just made
yeah so c5 only moved and then women
sort of took Swank like matrixes race
his only move maybe I can play just a
Firefox is great for just complete the
load for white so he played okay too but
now I can win an exchange and since we
passed time control now it's very easy
with 30 minutes on the clock I think it
played group t6 was a good technical
move it wasn't necessary to calculate
the consequences of 21 although I
thought it was also winning like
something judicata I briefly calculate
the king of to rugby 128 and I thought
that black escapes from checks here 25
kimchi it conceding in g7 Thanks 93 also
calculated going the 292 22 21 King III
and rocked it to him like it winning but
as I said it was unnecessary to do this
because rupee 6 was shrunk enough
because whenever white takes with the
Queen then I can take would either pond
okay maybe it was G pond and the White
Knight is very very passive it can't go
to d5 and blacks plan is just engage
with the king and to destroy at some
point so he played a 4 because white is
also in suits funk at medical have
played a 5 or a 6 but okay see we was
good enough forcing that the Queen's
exchange now we transpose into this pond
structures we I have just shown the
White Knight is very passive it's going
to go to d5 completely lost I think so
like its plan likes planet just in right
with the king
9b3 came g55 I think my five is a good
technical mode just preventing any kind
of sort of counter play with 94-95
although I think that communication
shows also winning but a 5-wood was much
easier and here my plunge resign because
just there's no way to preventing each
working
kingi astray like will divide the night
is completely restricted so it's like
this ma'am let it I managed to win
because I feel just like I'm quite tired
so now the most important to get sleep
okay very nicely done a great way to
start off this tournament group a the
strongest group of the three you know
this is the biggest one we've had and
Alexander you played in the Winter
Classic what are the differences you
perceive if any to be so far from two
months ago to today well I think first
of all there are three groups right now
flexes right so the C group was edit and
I think the C group is as good as the
group a it's actually stronger than the
B group yeah it is yeah so I think all
of the players who play in the group
pick would have played in a group yeah I
mean great organization and I think it's
getting better simply and well that's
awesome and Alexander hopefully I'll
tell you again later on hopefully let's
take a look at the standings after the
very first round for group a single
round-robin action begins after round
one group a has two players including a
photogs
'that have one point round two is
tomorrow
check out the pairing in this top group
group be round number one grandmaster
christian korilla joins me right now
after his victory over the phenomenal 17
year old Sean Zaya abdoumaliq tell us
what you thought of the game absolutely
it was a very difficult game I knew it
from the beginning that is going to be a
very difficult game she's very very
sharp tactically so what I what I tried
with my preparation is get her out of
her theory and then just try to play
like a slow game instead she she managed
to complicated quite quite heavily so
let's look at it so age for I want to
take back with the h1 and then
Reserve DF DF 140 initiative for the
attack Bishop g7 F 595 they state
knighted for now I created another
weakness only six Bishop c8 nice e6 I'm
trading one good square for another
basically after Bishop takes c6 take and
now I have the move Knight d5 coming at
any moment but she found a very nice
decent so queen c6 the idea is to go
Quinn c8 and attack my pawn on e6 and it
optically looks really good for me
because she goes Ruby 7 her pieces are
tied up I have very nice central Knight
her King seems to be a little bit weak
but there's a there's a big problem
because this Queen c8 Queen Queen takes
c6 comes and the structure in this
position is actually not that good for
me because of this this pawns right here
and if I lose this guy the night comes
to d3 the pressure continues on B to
this position might be might be worse in
no time so I had about 2 minutes
she had one way we were both in time
trouble and I played this tricky move
rook d1 kind of enticing her to play 93
which he did but it's a bad move also
Ruby 1 is simply defending against the
idea of Quincy 8 because I think I think
once again I'm not sure I want to look
look bad if computer says is completely
totally change yeah they will attack me
online and but it's always fun so maybe
quickly it was actually better
maybe Quincy it was actually not that
bad and now you if I take just take yeah
this might have been this might have
been her best chance in the position
because now if I go back then she just
capsules and my whole idea of playing
against the pond only seven with keep
preserving that super strong pawn on e6
is gone now the structure is actually
favorable for black so yeah I guess
queen c8 was was working my point of
roopd one was to to play against this
route 87 the sacrifice and now I assume
this should be winning with with a weak
King I go look at one maybe the other
work on d1 the King is very very weak so
this should be winning the problem is
there are 97 she just takes Queen takes
c6 and now if I take here then she can
take take take take take and I'm not
very happy in the same game I might be
yeah it's it's tough it's tough to
assess I think I still I still am a
little bit better because my roots are
quite active this root girl or steak on
a5 or played okay seven but this is a
very double-edged position it can end up
being lost in a matter of seconds for me
in a matter of moves so definitely would
have been the better move now she
blundered her last blunder of the game
93 she made the move b3 and now she
cannot take with the pony because Queen
takes b3 the B file opens up for me I
will take on c4 I get rid of my weakness
the route goes to B 1 this is just game
over so she played oak legs between
Bishop takes east 7 I think she makes
this in time trouble she taught that I
can only take with the night but then
Queen takes e4 and this position might
be okay for her but Bishop takes is 7
preserves the King Center Bishop h6
Bishop b5 Bishop g7 rook F on trying to
get all the way to X 7 root b2 and now I
had about 30 seconds left and my options
were Queen Queen e3 but I wasn't really
sure what happens if she just stay goes
back and pretty sure I'm
I'm winning but I couldn't see the the
exact way of doing that so I took on b2
which I think was a good decision and
after.look f7 despite the fact that I
just sacrificed my queen 97 it's coming
that's going to force her to give me the
Queen back because the king is so weak
in the center so this is just game over
Bishop takes c3 now I don't I'm not
worried about oops
about taking that Bishop rook at 1 or
not keep disrupting the position of the
of the King on the 8th whenever this
relieves the f5 she's not going she's
not going to be able to count which
would be 4 and this is just going over
right - minguk's da yeah mate was coming
yes made those coming she decided to
call it Kali tonight but uh yeah I guess
I'm happy with with the start of each
tournament I have to wipe in in the
first two games so I I hope I expected
to have to have a positive result I'm
happy very very disco game and I'm
looking forward to the next games well
and there is plenty of them there's
eight more rounds in Group B a and B
follow the same format and then C is
that crazy double round-robin but when
you're playing everybody just want do
you have a preference on who you are
most looking forward to playing in your
field I would have to look over though
yeah it's tougher now I would say not
because you know she's a she's a
celebrity a former US Women's Champion
so I'm definitely looking forward to a
battle on the board with her that's
awesome one more question before I let
you go the glasses I love the fashion
man what's going on with the glasses is
the learning huh yes they're not fashion
oriented they're they're Annie I need
them I have the prescription for the
glasses for a while now maybe a 1 and 1
year and a half but I was just not
wearing them you know and things got
really bad my vision got really bad I'm
getting blind so I'm sorry to hear that
right I said right that's right I'm
getting slowly slowly I'm I'm losing my
eyesight but yeah I will have to wear
this from from now on well they look
good thank you so good luck in the rest
of this event let's take a look at the
standings after just one round in Group
B and C the Romanian korilla is joined
by Alexander Lenderman and a wonder
Liang
at the top of Group B after one round
and here are the pairings for Group B
round 2 which is tomorrow at the regular
time of 1 p.m. central and look at this
bunch right here Group C the second
strongest of the three all draws today
tomorrow they play two rounds beginning
first at 11 a.m. Central this is an odd
round tomorrow because Group C has to
play 10 rounds altogether a and B only
play nine rounds so they squeeze in that
extra round tomorrow a little bit early
and for the rest of the tournament stay
with us through Wednesday May 24th as
every round begins at 1:00 p.m. with the
exception of the final day see the move
by move live as it happens at chess 24
calm and us chess champs calm